thank you what is it about the music we
make that makes it the music of
yesterday today and forever
maybe that today as a result of the
yesterday's spent in wooden churches
[Music]
singing the praises of our making joyous
harmony and love then part of it has to
be the songs we sang working under the
Blazing Sun to help pass the hard times
yesterday was also Bessie Smith Satchmo
New Orleans gospel choirs slavery folk
songs Bojangles
that the waters what about those rent
parties huh never those yesterday was
hot yesterday was hurting and yesterday
was the birthplace of today
you know today is 25 years of climbing
and building and opening doors and
breaking all the rules
today is also love songs
and guy and girl songs and songs of
protest and anger
[Music]
found gentleness and songs of wounds
left unattended for far too long
its songs to dance to
it's songs to march to to fly to to make
love to
and they love to
it's music pure and simple hard soulful
if he insists for the promise and
determination unity and humanity
I love ones today is the birthplace of
forever
[Music]
brotherbrother
thus far
you
bring me
don't eat Escalade
[Applause]
for only love
but talk to me
let's go
school